this is First Lady Grace Coolidge 100
years ago on the White House lawn she's
holding a Girl Scout cookie
and this is Tula in 2023 she's 11 and
has been a Girl Scout for six years I
wouldn't say it's well managed but it's
so enthusiastically managed that you
almost end up rooting for them their
success is due to a number of factors
Nostalgia yes but also smart sales
tactics strategic expansions and a
limited Supply this year they introduced
a new flavor the raspberry rally to be
sold only online within hours it was
gone there was no stock left this is the
economics of Girl Scout cookies
during the covid-19 pandemic Girl Scouts
tried to adapt their in-person tactics
to the online world with middling
success
2021 saw the biggest impact in terms of
Girl Scout cookies sales because all
these troops were having to balance
social distancing with selling their
cookies this year Girl Scouts have
resumed in-person and Booth sales but
the covet era trend of digital sales has
remained popular I think the girls are
mostly unfazed because
they are quite Nimble with working
online typically cookie selling season
runs from December to mid-april but a
shortage this year has for some regions
like New York City to sell cookies later
into the year so that the suppliers have
time to bake more cookies even with
adapted sales schedules Girl Scout
cookie customers may still be out of
luck for certain flavors this year's new
flavor the raspberry rally sold out in
hours but that very limited Supply could
actually benefit the Girl Scouts because
cookies are typically sold four months
out of the Year customers have to get
them while they're in season or risk
waiting another year the strategy I
think works really well because you keep
people's interest in the cookies by
introducing new flavors new flavors can
be modeled off of best-selling ones it
just triggers a whole bunch of other
memories associated with other Girl
Scout cookies you bank on the advantage
that you're giving people something new
but that's also sort of associated with
something that you're familiar with
whether it's a cookie or a childhood
memory certain cookies that don't sell
well are phased out but the organization
makes sure to keep long-standing
Classics like trefoils and thin mints
which have been around in some form
since at least the 1950s it's a classic
marketing strategy you can have like say
for example
a mascara or a lipstick That's a classic
color and something that you see
constant demand for to keep a classic
like the Thin Mints around is to Center
the campaign of selling cookies around
something that people instantly
recognize Girl Scouts list five skills
troops learn from selling cookies goal
setting decision making money management
people skills and business ethics the
way that the cookie program works is
that you set a goal it helps that those
goals are incentivized if you sell
enough you can get prizes I'm trying to
sell 2500 cookies because if you do that
you get a Broadway show as the prize and
that sounds really fun and I love
musicals so I definitely want to go to
one next is decision making a Girl Scout
must choose where and when to sell her
cookies how to Market them and help
decide where her troops Collective
cookie fund should go the key player in
figuring out the distribution of these
cookies the parent a lot of the parents
are often troop leaders especially the
moms or they participate in other parts
of the program like being a co-cookie
chair they take upon themselves a lot of
the logistics and the planning and where
their children will be at any given time
to sell these cookies usually the troop
or a girl scouts parents purchase the
cookies before any sales are made so
they're on the hook to make up the money
that they have already spent in buying
or procuring the boxes that they said
that they were going to sell all sales
proceeds according to the Girl Scouts go
to the Troops to pay for that Year's
upcoming activities Girl Scouts receive
scripts and training to get to know the
products they also receive advice on
their sales pitches the goal is to
sharpen their people skills it has
definitely helped me talk to people and
like communicate what I want typically
Girl Scouts sell cookies to their family
and friends or customers in the
neighborhood it's still very much a
Grassroots movement no one sees it as
you know a big cookie no one looks at it
as this big corporate grab that you
associate with some of the bigger Brands
this is as homegrown as it comes even
with the parents behind the major
operations the selling point is still
the Girl Scouts themselves don't buy
cookies from an alligator don't buy
copies from a giraffe
buy cookies from Girl Scouts because
they're really good there is some
criticism regarding the fact that you
know if you're a rich parent you can
just throw money at the problem buy up
all the boxes you know done the
program's done you've made the money
everything's hunky-dory but that defeats
the purpose as many parents have told me
of teaching their children financial
literacy and having them go through the
process of learning procurement learning
distribution learning sales and then
learning to manage money actual physical
money you can see them physically you
know doing the math in their head
calculating what they've got to give
back to a customer and I think if a
parent just swoops in and buys all the
boxes or buys too many boxes it defeats
the purpose of what the program stands
for and learning effective sales tactics
like offering samples of the
underselling types of cookies or
encouraging customers to buy more than
one box of their favorites helps the
next year run smoothly I think the Girl
Scout cookies
inhabit a very unique equal system when
it comes to selling cookies compared to
your everyday brands that you're
familiar with whether they're Oreos or
any kind of digestive biscuits or
whatever cookies that people prefer
their main draw is that they are
available for a very short period of
time every year and you also Bank on
people's memories of eating these
cookies as they were growing up
come out